use less than or greater than for this
little brackets thing to write a true
sentence so they essentially want us to
say whether forty five and six hundred
and seventy five thousandths is greater
than or less than forty five and six
hundred and forty five thousandths so
let's look at each of these numbers so
I'm going to write them on top of each
other so the first number is forty five
and six hundred and seventy-five
thousandths and the second number is
forty five and six hundred and forty
five thousands now when you look at
everything here the only place where
these two numbers are different is in
the is in the hundredths of place we
have seven hundredths here and we have
four hundredths here everything is the
same so this number is going to be
greater this number is greater than
forty five point six four five or six
hundred and forty-five thousand so let
me write that down just to make sure we
know what we're doing forty five and six
hundred and seventy five thousandths or
forty five point six seven five is
definitely greater than forty five point
six four five or forty five and six
hundred and forty-five thousandths